we sent our support and solidarity to
Australia the European Union stands
ready to help Australian people on
Sunday yesterday my colleague
Commissioner lenarcik reached out and
spoke to the Australian Minister little
proud and he reiterated the union's
readiness to assist Australia in this
moment of crisis australia is home to
truly unique species including 200 types
of mammals that do not exist anywhere
else in the world in face of this
destruction
complacency should have no place and the
EU needs to remain a leader in fighting
climate change when these things happen
so I in a mission via proof of the a
catastrophe shoots Mahan is most
catastrophic decent hours masses give
arsonist these beliefs of all n set in a
heart a who I saw on dream oblique
heightened and reached at noon saw him I
was Naamah situation and he fed tsuki
realized saves first and the Moose of
Australian and sign a climate silicic
heightened on this day the four hours
dust is it silly arrived Verdun ow
after aunties crows impotency eyes and
annoy a barn and again at Varma remote
the other year the tree still inherited
risk for variable u monopsony Akkad is
Vitoria odami rocks on a gather risk for
us cooks plundered madam food stand it
directly a commode politics of the if
all fenomena eve ever saw she knock us
australian
so we provide not three of the regulars
affirming sleep to the or another or on
her so Marian come Adobe track to summon
healed Vaughn like so much it dearly
will be drawn me her if Rene Rupa we
must your amecameca mere new into
sevilla treaty integer grief empty suit
on new you are we must not do like those
railings we must do as our own
scientists and our own children demand
we must invest and innovate in fire
adaptation and civic rotation and we
must make our arrest EU and F is
capabilities a global leader as part of
the external green new deal
Adachi my effectiveness nicodemus Eureka
at the maximum a mirror image map really
adapt to what's on a municipal minke
australia buddha harrison implicados
leon hospital school model ooh knee
compatible on a horsy Otonashi furniture
Rena premise is a global initiative also
in transforming our own Nick politic
napot l'homme illusion acetone a Takashi
Australia priest Elena exotic scar
Denton I mean she continent tombow she
is Austin asam how can a prime minister
make fear of the costs of climate action
more terrifying than the actual results
of climate change themselves of course
this is not only an Australian problem
it is related to one of the biggest
global challenges of our time in which
we all bear responsibility the
devastating Australian fires underline
the magnitude of the effects of inaction
at the recent cope 25 climate conference